jingle bells jingle bell jingle bell
rock
oh [__] this is it [__] you've
been waiting all [__] morning for
your uncle Joey Joey where you been we
were building [__] we need to [__]
breathe the smell of [__] victory
understand me very [__]
Christmas uncle Joey here checking in
with you [__] direct I don't want
no misunderstandings you've been sitting
there for hours building [__] it's time
to get your head together a few bong
hits for [__] Santa never hurt nobody
understand me
you're beautiful we made it another
[__] Christmas all the hype and ends
now well guess what you [__] opened
up your presents you had [__] lunch
with your family you're back to [__]
Monday [__] you understand me
it's still Monday I don't give a [__]
how you dress it up what smoke you blow
up your ass it's still [__] Monday so
jingle bells and all that [__] but we
get back to business tomorrow the real
[__] savages out there we're already
doing our goals for the [__] here
what we want from 2018 what we're gonna
tolerate what we're gonna do and what we
ain't gonna [__] do you know
why because we're [__] soldiers [__]
all this Jingle Bell [__] it's over you
spent your Guinness your credit card is
tapped and now you're ready to [__]
dig into 2018 cuz it's over the kids is
for the kids yeah jingle bells your
[__] hat with your red [__]
sweater like an [__] but it's over
we're ready to go to [__] war now
Joey what's with the hip beating on
Christmas until we're gonna smoke some
reefer we're gonna smoke some reefer how
you [__] doing uncle Joey here
coming at you no there's no podcast and
I we ain't doing dick tomorrow we make a
comeback heavy we in the year off for
the [__] bang you follow me
what am i smoke before he dick I'm
smoking that I got perennial I got
Skywalker
I got classic we don't [__] around here
you gotta see the [__] patron I got
I've been buying a half ounce of weed a
day stocking up just January first
they're gonna cut us down 18% and you
know uncle Joey don't get her an 18%
that's for [__] Moop the mooks
I gotta smoke this [__] they gave
[__] Jesus before they push them in
the stomach you understand me like a
[__] doctor here we are Studio City
California and a lot of these [__]
businesses open but I don't give a [__]
you know why cuz the Russian reach doors
open I'm gonna take a ride I'm just
saying a lot of my girls over that
sunset arable they got [__] stars a
debt ready to [__] go I'm gonna go
clean him out to the having a mood to
eat some [__] stars I got at wishy
200 we're going deep today the Weight
Watchers I got three points it's a new
lifestyle Weight Watchers you get
[__] three points on seafood I'm
eating seafood like [__] flip it
today
I mean dolphin I mean everything I'm
gonna [__] deep in the murky waters
anyway let's smoke this [__] ball
Joey witch what the [__] man here beaten
we will get together
oh well you've a shout-out to all the
church families out there from the
[__] our ways the Bible lingers in
memory your father dawn my [__]
Savage is out there lawn rosin kooky
spooky
Timmy Holloway [__] jr. Cleo [__]
my family in Austin we're gonna see them
crystal and Bobby and [__] January
January 20th we're invading Austin Texas
I don't give a [__] you stand out list
you better come down cuz I don't know if
I'm going back to Texas just yet
Washington in my spot I'm gonna be in
Papa doze eating like a [__]
then the next we gotta go to Charlotte
like a [__] Savage and I'm excited
for Charlotte that's it that's all I got
enjoying doing dick I'm sticking with
the Weight Watchers I'm [__] doing my
podcast I'm going to jujitsu I'm writing
and that's it that's the goal for 2018
hopefully the book will be up hopefully
Netflix will give us a half hour if not
who gives a [__] what bad [__]
with a church family we can't be stopped
Joey you're going off tangent again
smoke some leaf I know I know I'm sorry
smoke signals the [__] Santa you
follow me ah tremendous my lung feels
[__] great anyway alright so
Christmas is over now what's the
planning we sit there all week with your
thumb in your ass and mine [__] yourself
[__] no you get 2018 on your [__]
little scope what you gonna do but most
importantly how you gonna [__] do it
are you gonna take these [__]
and put your dick down their throat and
go here I've arrived [__] we're
imposing our will in 2018 to - all right
one more bullets it was [__] sky walk
and see what this [__] up is about
empty you know we don't [__] around we
smoke it right to the root if I was a
hook I'd give the best blow job in town
let's be honest I could suck these
[__] pipes down to nothing
Alysha pilot to Bombardier pilot to
Bombardier we had a nice Christmas
saying my daughter's happy my wife is
happy I give my wife a like I want
looking around I can find them and it's
a birthday on Thursday to boot that's a
double [__] whammy
I'm looking around I went on this small
[__] coffee shop there the statue of
a cat with three pigeons on it and I
thought about my threat my three dead
little favorite cat so I gave her that
and we [__] broke down this morning
to say we loved those [__] cats so
anyway it happens on a Christmas [__]
day but tomorrow yeah hi were you
[__] I'm gonna write my dad I'm
gonna take a little ride go to [__]
sunset arrabal real quick over to the
park build the [__] Barbie Dreamhouse
and maybe take a ride over get some
[__] animals just to see the girls at
the weed store and that's it it's a
light day for me I'm still on nope no
comedy till the first of the year I'm a
no comment can't write it can't look at
it can't get on stage like come on 2018
like a bat out of [__] hell that's how
you want uncle Joey and we [__] fly
it up and ready to [__] go all right
beside that listen I want to wish you
and your families a merry [__]
Christmas in the best [__] New Year
you've ever had in your life and if you
don't know anything about me I'm saying
this to you sincerely especially to the
church family well we've been through
one how we hang out now you know you
know I'm coming from I'm a [__] you
know I'm no [__] eye candy but my
heart's in the right place you know I'm
saying I did some fucked-up [__] who
gives a [__] that's the past I would
thirty years ago I'm a new man I'm
trying to pass on to you [__]
the mistakes I've made so you don't make
them see you come on think gay you don't
let nobody hold you down you don't give
a [__] jack I don't care if you got
twenty families I don't care if you got
a missing eye I don't care if you
[__] leaks you can't
start on a daily [__] these
[__] I'm ugly I'm fat I'm all
but I don't give a [__] like a knowledge
of a [__] fat Japanese Buddha
whatever the [__] they are you
understanding anyway I have a great day
where your families keep me able to [__]
you up keep smoking reefer get off those
[__] opiate - please stop with those
things already you're [__] killing
yourself to live the same way look at me
look at how I ended up [__] holes in
my face fat stomach titties the reefer
Chinese food twenty-two push-ups a day
and you tell these [__] to suck
your dick and you'll live forever look
at Ozzy Osbourne and Keith Richards you
think they eat kale and they didn't get
the [__] out of here right so don't
believe the hype be yourself you'll live
to [__] your hundred fifty-five years
old so you be yourself that's it I'm
gonna be me
who the [__] gives a [__] smoking dope
with the church
and I listen to [__] music giggling I
hope I die of a heart attack giggling
and laughing I don't give a [__] because
they learn to be upset about pick up
your dick it's Christmas Day [__] you
got a family tell them all to suck it
they give them all a hug and tell them
this is your [__] year you know why
there's uncle Joey sent your
[__] merry [__] Christmas
that's what the Christmas card I'm
sending your [__]
I love you have a great day
we're your families hug them cuz you
never know if the Koreans gonna send a
missile over here tonight and don't
forget they can't stop in 2018 as the
Cuban said they didn't get my my Taylor
Bing I hope visit okay forget that
wrong color but wait that Ron told in
Bolivia
I mean mapping the Santissima III go
higher
I miss it a meaning about mommy over
Gulu I don't know what that means before
to figure it out comes up just get that
[__] Amelia chick on your phone to
tell you I love your mother [__] stay
black say strong it's Christmas Day I'll
see you [__] tomorrow in the
Church of what's happened now tip top
Magoo ready to go stay black uncle Joey
loves you
Merry Christmas